okay so the symbol today is uh
mu
which is this the 12th greek letter so
mu can actually mean lots of different
things in physics it can mean things
like friction it can mean the
permeability but today we're focusing on
the representation of mu as the magnetic
moment
so it's it's a quantity which tells us
about the
strength of magnetic field that a
particular object will generate
so so there are lots of things that
generate magnetic fields we can have a
bar magnet like this thing we can have a
compass needle of course which is like
another bar magnet we can have what's
that compass what's that that's it's um
felix who's this obscure swiss character
i think where does that come from uh
it's come from my son who's
when he was much younger so you might be
embarrassed
see that one video that's embarrassing
okay so so another thing that would
generate a
magnetic field is a coil of wire if we
put current through it so all of these
would have associated with the magnetic
moment mu
and the strength of the magnetic moment
will tell us how strong the magnetic
dipole field that each of these
different things would generate
so these generate quite strong magnetic
moments so this might generate a
magnetic moment of say 0.1
amps meters squared but what i wanted to
focus on today is the magnetic moment
that's generated by the hydrogen nucleus
which is a much much smaller magnetic
moment so the order of
about 10 to the minus 26 so
the magnetic moment from the hydrogen
nucleus arises because the hydrogen
nucleus has a positive charge and also
it has a quantum mechanical property
which is a bit harder to explain known
as spin
if you think about a
a spinning ball of charge
as it moves around
let's try and put it like that
the charge is moving so this is a very
hand waving hand waving description
of what's going on but a moving charge
corresponds to an electric current and
so we can sort of imagine we can make a
simple model that the rotating spinning
nuclear charge
positive charge gives rise to a current
which gives rise to a magnetic field and
that's the magnetic moment of the
hydrogen nucleus
so the hydrogen nucleus is interesting
because
the nuclear magnetism is of the hydrogen
nucleus is what underlies most of
magnetic resonance imaging which is of
course a technique that was developed
here in nottingham by sir peter
mansfield and it's one that we currently
do
do research in and continue to develop
so we get the signals that we use to
make images from hydrogen nuclei the
unit from you can write the unit for
magnetic moments in in different ways
the normal one is amps meters squared so
you can kind of the easiest way to
understand that i guess is if you think
about a coil like this
this this coil has
will when we connect it to a power
supply would carry a current
current's measured in amps
and then it has an area inside it so
the area of this the sort of circular
cross-section of this we could measure
it in meters squared so the magnetic
moment depends on the products of the
the area and the current and also in
fact the number of turns that are
present there
so that makes sense easily for this kind
of arrangement for for something like a
bar magnet it's sort of less obvious but
it has the same dimensional units
it's really an amazing technique it's
suddenly grew out of pure physics as
well it's something you could never have
predicted really if you've gone back
40 years and predicted that this
physics idea of measuring signals from
nuclear magnets could be used one day to
make beautiful images of someone's brain
you would never have guessed that
something completely unpredictable
but it's really turned out something
grew out of pure physics and it's turned
out to be incredibly useful